hey youtubers is charlie so huge news
for The Walking Dead spinoff Robert
Kirkman just revealed what all the
characters are going to be and what the
time frame is going to be so I'm going
to be doing a breakdown of all that only
six people were on out so it is likely
they'll continue to add some more
secondary characters to the pilot before
they shoot it the fact that they're this
far into the process means there's a
solid chance that if they can finish the
pilot by the time the regular show comes
back for break next year like the second
half of season 5 the network can make a
decision and put the show into
production for a fall 2015 debut if they
want that doesn't mean that it'll go
down that way it just means that if
everything stays on track and they shoot
it in time we might get to watch it as
early as Comic Con 2015 so I'll talk
more about that after I explain the
characters and really good news I know
you guys will like this the walking dead
giveaway the weekly giveaway that's
going to run with all the episode starts
right now so all you have to do to enter
this first round is just be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video okay
so here we go so these six character
descriptions are straight from Robert
Kirkman number one is Shawn Cabrera he's
a Latino male in his early 40s he's a
good man trying to do right by everyone
in his life I'm gonna choose to think of
him is like the Rick of the group for
now or maybe a cross between Rick and
Shane if Shane had gotten completely
nuts number two is Cody Cabrera Shawn's
whip smart and rebellious teenage son
known as the angriest kid in town I'm
gonna think of him as like a younger
version of Darryl who's got Glenn's
brain he has mischief managed written
all over him like he's got the brains to
really get in trouble number three is
Nancy Tompkins she's a 30-something
single mom with two kids Nancy looks
like the girl next door but there's an
edge tour so I'm gonna think of her as a
cross between Andrea if she had a child
just because she was in her mid-30s to
and seasons one and two Carol Carol is
about ten years older than what Nancy's
going to be but she's like the template
walking dead tiger mom and that kind of
sounds like what Nancy's going to be
soft and caring like Andrea but
capricious enough that she'll swing to
Carol levels of badassery when pushed
number four is Nick Tompkins he's
Nancy's screwed-up teenage son he's too
old to stay
home but too scared to flee I'll explain
the flee part after I explained all the
characters just cuz it kind of deals
with the timeframe that this show is
gonna take place in Nick sounds like an
early version of Bob just reading the
description for him you know screwed-up
teenager too chicken to leave home he
feels like he has future alcoholic
written all over him like future
substance abuser number five is Ashley
Tompkins she's Nancy's mostly
level-headed teenage daughter her
ambition is in direct proportion to or
older brothers failures I know that
sounds kind of cryptic but just take
that she's very ambitious she loves her
mom but it's time to get at a Dodge so
from the character description she
sounds exactly like what Beth is going
to become in season 5 or what she
started to become at the end of seasons
for if you remember at the end of season
4 1 Beth and Daryl or like on their
little side trip she got really pissed
at him when he just wanted to sit around
and accept their fate she became a big
call to action for him so it sounds like
this new Ashley person might be a big
call to action for the other people in
the group the sixth and last person is
named Andrea Chapman I know there was
already in Andrea in the main show but
Kirkman explained that they have no
relation to each other and using the
same name isn't meant to be an easter
egg or anything she just also happens to
be named Andrea she's described as a
somewhat wilted flower child who has
retreated to the outskirts of the city
to recover from a horrible marriage
actually you know reading that she does
kind of sound like Andrea say if she had
Carroll's life pretty apocalypse so
there's a whole lot that we can take
away from this group just based on the
makeup so there's two single parent
families one with a dad one with a mom I
guess you could make all the Brady Bunch
jokes you want but it does seem like
they're making the spin-off show a
family-based group at least at the
beginning this is a big change from the
main show that through a bunch of
strangers together with a few scattered
families these people on the spin-off
show will just be much more of a tight
family unit from the start I think the
hope is that by starting these
characters off in a much more intimate
relationship we as the audience will
just bond with them faster I do tend to
feel closer to a bonded group of
characters usually that's the way it
happens on a show like a group of
characters comes together and then you
really start to connect with them so I
think that they're just trying to
speed that up with this spinoff show on
the other end of that spectrum if you
take a look at the main show Rick
literally just acknowledged Darrell is
his brother at the end of season four it
took them four years to become a family
like that I suppose you could argue that
the survivors became a family last
season whenever they moved into the
prison with respect to the main show so
many people come and so many people die
off each season it's really hard to get
attached to people so just taking a look
at some of the younger people you do
have some gender parity so I guess we
can start the ship train now or
something like that I don't know I feel
like relationships on the walking dead
are like a death knell but you basically
have a teenage girl and a teenage boy in
the group from two different families
and two single women with one single
adult man so I'm sure there'll be some
drama there at some point I will be
interested to see if they go straight
for a love triangle with the adults
there's not much time for romance in the
age of the apocalypse but I guess that
kind of makes it sound like an x-men
sequel which is actually a pretty badass
movie that I can't wait to see the
really interesting thing that I heard
about them developing the show with
these older teenagers is that they
wanted to get around some of the
problems they had when they had to shoot
with Chandler Riggs as a child child
labor laws just make it so that you only
get to shoot with kids for like half a
normal day if they're really young like
say Carl in season one you can only
shoot with them for like a few hours a
day sometimes even less than that so
normal shoots can take up to like 18
hours so it can be a big problem if you
have a lot of kids on a show so a couple
big points though none of these
characters are from the comics and we
don't know where this is going to be set
we don't know which city it's going to
be in really the biggest question I know
you guys are all asking is when is this
going to take place and is it going to
tie into the main show the show is
rumored to be prequel but it's going to
take place in the early days of the
outbreak it's going to chronicle their
attempts to contain the virus so there
will be massive groups of walkers but
the population won't be nearly as
decimated like society won't have been
completely destroyed but the walkers
will start popping up everywhere so
we'll be seeing the world react to the
walkers for the first time Robert
Kirkman is doing most of the writing
himself with the help of his partner
it's Skybound Dave Erickson ericsson is
going to be the official showrunner I
know it'd be interesting to see Robert
Kirkman run a show but he is way too
busy for that
many as the comic and the main show that
he still has to work on just to talk
about connecting both the shows so the
spin-off will be at least two to three
years before seasons one of the main
show so there won't be any direct
crossover but they probably will
reference things that we've seen on the
main show behind the scenes though there
will be a lot of crossover between
production teams the differences is that
Robert Kirkman Skybound company is in
charge of the spin-off if you remember
Frank Darabont actually developed the
main show originally with kirkman's
health at a time Kirkman just did not
have the ability to produce a show
himself so AMC did a lot of heavy
lifting if you guys didn't see it at
Comic Con this summer Kirkman did this
whole big Skybound panel about the
comics in the games and all this other
stuff that he's developing so he has
like a universe of Walking Dead content
across all platforms that he's doing on
his own ok so the next really important
question is is when are we going to be
able to watch this the short answer is
is probably in 2015 probably fall 2015
as i said earlier they're casting right
now so if they can finish the pilot by
the spring next year you know unless
there's some huge catastrophe AMC can
order to series and then they can shoot
episodes for fall 2015 release just for
example the main show start shooting
each new season during the summer so if
they can start shooting this spinoff
show during the summer they'll have
episodes ready to air by October 2015
that's if they decide to air this series
alongside the maid show they could
always choose to air it during another
part of the year whenever it's on the
air Walking Dead is like the most
popular show in the world it owns Sunday
nights that doesn't guarantee that the
spin-off show is going to do that too so
they might air that on a different night
if you guys don't know about the flash
TV show that's coming up next week it's
a spinoff from arrow the CW is doing
both those it's airing them on separate
nights so AMC might do the same type of
thing where the spin-off airs on a
separate night from the main show since
they're still working on the pilot
there's no word on how many episodes per
season they're envisioning this show as
it could be 16 like the main show or
could be 13 like an HBO show or even 10
like Game of Thrones they probably won't
make a decision on that till after they
see the pilot it just depends on how
much money they think they can make from
it and how much is going to cost to
produce
the good news though is that if you can
make it to San Diego Comic Con 2015 next
number in July there's a ninety-nine
percent chance that they'll screen the
pilot there may be during the walking
dead main show panel maybe they'll do a
separate panel for the spin-off show
because they'll probably have the cast
by then that's all unless something goes
horribly horribly wrong the good news is
is that it's going to be candid with the
main show I feel like that's the
important part you know both shows will
be able to reference each other univ
characters don't necessarily crossover i
think on the main show right now where
we are in current day it's like
2009-2010 and this spinoff show is going
to be about two to three years before
seasons one so it's gonna be like
2003-2004 something like that kirkman
has refused to say exactly when the
outbreak started but essentially it was
around 2003 and the show will take place
no later than like a year after that let
me know that which of these new
characters are you most excited to learn
about and what kind of a villain do you
think that they're gonna cast for the
show I know I said that it's not going
to take from the comic books like it's
not going to take comic book characters
that doesn't mean that they could take a
comic book character change its name or
give their qualities to a character on
the show they do that all the time on
the main show so we only have two more
weeks before walking dead is back that's
October 12 when it gets here i'll be
doing bonus videos reviews q and A's and
the weekly giveaway just like last year
I'll totally be doing a couple more
bonus videos before then but be sure to
subscribe to get everything if there's
anything that you guys really want to
talk about in particular just let me
know in the comments right now click
here for my breakdown of the season five
trailer and click here for my top five
Rick Grimes moments thank you so much
for watching so let's all high five
don't forget shield is tonight I'll see
you guys a little bit
you